[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Welcome, friends
and colleagues,
to Radcliffe Day 2017.
As many of you know, if you
were across the street with us,
I'm Liz Cohen.
I'm Dean of the
Radcliffe Institute
for Advanced Study at Harvard.
And it is a pleasure to
have you all here with us
under this big tent.
Years ago, the size of
this tent was aspirational.
We imagined that one day, it
would be absolutely filled
with Radcliffe and Harvard
graduates, institute fellows,
university friends,
and participants
in our many programs.
Today, we don't
have to imagine it.
Attendance here
at Radcliffe Yard
has doubled in just
the past five years.
And we are joined by a global
online audience as well.
I am especially pleased
to welcome Drew Gilpin
Faust, Harvard President and
Founding Dean of the Radcliffe
Institute;
[APPLAUSE]
Provost Alan Garber; numerous
deans and other university
leaders; and Bill Lee,
Senior Fellow of the Harvard
Corporation; along
with many other members
of Harvard's governing boards.
A warm welcome to the
Harvard Alumni Association,
the Radcliffe Dean's Advisory
Council, the Schlesinger
Library Council, the Radcliffe
Associates Program, the Anne
Radcliffe's Society, as well as
past members of the Radcliffe
College, Board of Trustees,
and Alumni Association.
And we are thrilled to
have the honorable Maura
Healy joining us as well.
[APPLAUSE, CHEERING]
Just in case you
didn't know, she
is the attorney general of the
Commonwealth of Massachusetts,
a member of the class of
1992, and Chief Marshall
of yesterday's
commencement ceremonies.
And of course, a special welcome
to Radcliffe medalist Judy
Woodruff, our
afternoon speakers--
[APPLAUSE]
--our afternoon speakers, Walter
Isaacson and Michele Norris,
and all of the participants
in this morning's
excellent discussion.
I am also delighted
to welcome back
everyone who is here to
attend college reunion,
including the reunion classes
of 1942 and '47, '52 and '57,
'62 and '67, '72 and
'77, '82 and '87, '92
and '97, 2002, 2007, 2012, and
we have some newest graduates
in the class of 2017.
[APPLAUSE]
In addition, we welcome Bunting
fellows, Radcliffe fellows,
and our Radcliffe
research partners
who are undergraduates who
work closely with our fellows
on their research.
Please join me in congratulating
the members of the earliest
class represented here today,
the great class of 1941.
[APPLAUSE]
When so many of us
are gathered together,
our thoughts turn to members
of our Radcliffe community
who are no longer with us.
This year, we
experienced the loss
of Mary Maples Dunn who
directed the Schlesinger Library
and then led Radcliffe
as interim head
while Radcliffe College made
the transition to the Radcliffe
Institute for Advanced Study.
We also lost Susan
Story Lyman who
served as chair of
the board of trustees,
among many other roles
in her decades of service
to Radcliffe College.
For them and for
the many others who
are missed and in
our thoughts today,
please join me in a
moment of silence.
The Radcliffe Institute
is devoted to the pursuit
of new knowledge
wherever it may be
found by whomever is seeking
it, whether fellows, students,
faculty, or public audiences.
That new idea might
lie in medieval history
or in the observation
of a black hole.
It might be found in the pages
of a diary at the Schlesinger
Library or on the walls of the
Johnson-Kulukundis Family Art
Gallery.
We believe, as an institute
for advanced study,
that it is our responsibility
to be both timely and timeless
and that our support
of inquiry is even more
necessary in tumultuous times.
You can see this conviction
in Radcliffe's offerings
this past year, from
our current exhibition
about the history of
Title IX to our science
symposium on the impact of
climate change on the world's
oceans to our conference on
universities and slavery.
In the year ahead, we will
launch a major programming
initiative on citizenship,
celebrate the Schlesinger
Library's 75th anniversary, and
welcome a fellowship class that
includes a former UN ambassador,
a Turing Award-winning
scientist, and a Pulitzer
Prize-winning novelist.
I hope that many
of you will join us
next fall for an exciting
calendar of events.
In just the first
few months, we will
mount a panel on the present and
future of Boston's art museums,
a lecture by physicist
Brian Greene,
a day-long science symposium on
epidemics, and much, much more.
You can get details
at our website.
Radcliffe is a very
busy, dynamic place
where all that we do is
made possible by support
from so many of you here today.
In fact, we have
set a new record.
I am thrilled to announce that
the Radcliffe campaign has just
surpassed its $70 million goal.
[APPLAUSE]
We have already received
over 20,000 gifts,
attracted more than
1,000 first-time donors,
and diversified
our support base.
And fortunately, we
still have a year
to go before the campaign ends.
Please join me in
expressing appreciation
to members of our
Dean's Advisory Council
and Schlesinger Library Council
and to Sid Knafel and Susan
Wallach for their extraordinary
leadership as campaign
co-chairs.
[APPLAUSE]
Will those members please stand?
We're asking our council
members please to stand.
[APPLAUSE]
I cannot possibly cover here
every accomplishment made
possible by the campaign.
But I'll just share
a few highlights.
We have built up a robust
public programming wing
of the institute-- you
experienced some of that this
morning--
what we call Academic
Ventures, as our wing
to complement the Schlesinger
Library and the fellowship
program as the three pillars
of the Radcliffe Institute.
We have expanded
the Schlesinger's
undergraduate
teaching activities.
We have established
directorships, fellowships,
and professorships.
We have launched a major
campus renewal project.
We have initiated a
university-wide student
public art competition
and created flexible funds
for the sciences, the arts,
the library, and much more.
I am absolutely delighted
with our progress,
but we are not done yet.
The campaign concludes
in June of 2018.
And we will continue to
pursue our aspirations
as Harvard's Institute
for Advanced Study
and to increase our
impact in the world.
Going forward, we will
focus our energies
on raising funds for
unmet campaign priorities.
We aim to fully endow the
fellowship program to provide
our 50 talented fellows
a year with the highest
quality of
experience, regardless
of their personal resources.
We intend to diversify
the Schlesinger Library's
collections to
broaden and deepen
the history of American women
that library researchers are
able to write
today and tomorrow.
We will grow the Exploratory
and Advanced Seminars
program run by academic
ventures to meet
increasing demand from Harvard
faculty and Radcliffe fellows
who wish to pursue
collaborative research
and explore even more deeply
in their areas of expertise.
And we plan to renovate
Radcliffe's buildings
to provide state of
the art facilities
to make possible
the highest level
of scholarly and artistic
work and public events.
It is fitting that today,
Radcliffe Day 2017,
we are celebrating
this campaign success
and our continued
ambitions with all of you.
Thank you for helping us
to reach this milestone
and for your continued
enthusiasm for the Radcliffe
Institute.
[APPLAUSE]
The Radcliffe Campaign has
reached one kind of milestone.
But our society has been
living through a pivotal time
of a different sort.
In recent years,
the American media
has undergone dramatic shifts.
And all of us here have
experienced some elements
of that transition.
To get our news, we used
to snap open a newspaper
or tune the radio dial.
Now we might turn
on a television
or, increasingly, swipe
a screen for a headline.
Unlike some evolutions,
in this case,
the new hasn't eclipsed the old.
These various forms of
media co-exist together.
With all the
options, it turns out
that Americans,
on a weekly basis,
now follow the news most
on television, followed
by their computers and
other electronic devices,
then radio, and then
finally, print publications.
I was going to express
condolences to the print
journalists in the room.
But after hearing Jonah remind
us that it all comes down
to print, I feel better.
In other words,
television is number one
when it comes to shaping what
we know, when we know it,
and whom we trust.
It is especially
important in this context
to recognize that it
was only four years ago
that the United States gained
its first all-female TV news
team when Gwen Ifill and Judy
Woodruff were named co-anchors
of the PBS News Hour.
[APPLAUSE]
In covering the news,
they made the news.
Judy and Gwen weren't
just a stellar team
of journalists with decades
of combined experience
on camera and in print.
They became part of the
history of American journalism.
The importance of an
all-women news team
is perhaps best summed
up in Gwen's own words.
She said, and I quote her, "When
I was a little girl watching
programs like this, because
that's the kind of nerdy family
we were, I would look
up and not see anyone
who looked like me in any way--
no women, no people of color.
I'm very keen about the fact
that a little girl now watching
the news, when they see me
and Judy sitting side by side,
it will occur to them that
that's perfectly normal--
that it won't seem like any
big breakthrough at all."
Well, maybe someday, a
team like Judy and Gwen
won't seem like a major change.
But we who have been
watching the news longer
know that we actually
have witnessed
two big breakthroughs--
Judy's and Gwen's.
Neither had an easy
start in journalism.
They experienced
resistance and rejection.
Like a certain current
Massachusetts senator,
they were warned.
They were given explanations.
Nevertheless, they persisted.
[APPLAUSE]
Judy is a proud graduate of
Duke where she was active,
not surprisingly, in
publications, the student
union, and student government.
She followed her
interest in politics
to an internship in Washington
where her enthusiasm
collided with
warnings against women
pursuing political careers.
So she decided instead
to cover politics
and applied for jobs at
local television stations
back home in Atlanta.
One station turned
her down because,
and I quote, "we already
have a woman reporter."
She could, however,
be a secretary.
Judy remained undeterred.
She worked her way
up by reporting
on stories across
Georgia, including
covering Jimmy Carter's
presidential campaign.
She served as a White
House correspondent,
the anchor of a PBS
documentary series,
and a senior
correspondent at CNN.
Longtime News Hour colleague
Jim Lehrer offered an insight
into Judy's success
when he said, "No matter
how hard everyone
else was working,
Judy was working harder."
Her young colleagues
today still agree.
In a recent New
York Times profile,
a 27-year-old politics
producer said about Judy,
"We all struggle just
to keep up with her.
She's just such a workhorse."
And she has worked everywhere.
We saw her reporting
in Washington
just after the assassination
attempt on President Reagan,
from outside the Murrah Federal
building in Oklahoma City,
on the ground in Chechnya,
and in Chicago on the night
President Obama
was first elected.
Wherever she is, Judy
delivers first-rate reporting
and smart, incisive interviews.
Because she asks
better questions,
she gets better answers.
When Susan Rice, President
Obama's White House National
Security Adviser,
was ready to give
her first interview
after leaving office,
it was with Judy.
When Vice President Mike Pence
gave his first television
interview after taking
office, it was with Judy.
Now there may not be much
else that Mike Pence and Susan
Rice agree on.
But they both
trust Judy Woodruff
to communicate their views
to the American public.
Judy has also won the trust
of the many journalists whose
careers she has helped launch
and support as founding
co-chair of the International
Women's Media Foundation.
The reason why so many
professionals admire Judy
is the same reason
viewers do and why
we are honoring her today.
We respect her intelligence,
and we rely on her integrity.
Gwen's career, like Judy's,
began with some bumps.
Gwen was interning
at the Boston Herald
at the height of
the Boston busing
crisis of the 1970s when she
found a threatening racist note
on her desk.
Given that climate,
it is no surprise
that she was initially
reluctant to accept the job
offer from the Herald
upon her graduation
from Simmons College
a year later.
But she did need a job.
So she returned to
the Herald after all.
Years later, she said about
that decision, and I quote,
"I knew if I got my foot in
the door, I could do it."
And Gwen did far more than
get her foot in the door.
She went on to report for the
Baltimore Sun, The Washington
Post, and The New York Times,
as a White House correspondent,
and then to NBC television.
Even as the news cycle
sped up, Gwen never
stopped being respected
as an impeccable writer,
a sharp analyst, and
a caring colleague.
When Gwen became the moderator
of the PBS program Washington
Week in Review in 1999, she also
became the first black woman
to host a national political
talk show on television.
Along with her
professional expertise,
she brought her dinner table
experiences, growing up as one
of six children in a family
where every evening's
conversation drew on
knowledge of current events
and honed sharp
critical thinking.
Holding her own
among her siblings
trained her to
set high standards
for the level of discourse
and to manage her guests
masterfully.
With Gwen running the show,
there were disagreements,
but tough exchanges
were not disagreeable.
Over the decades,
millions of Americans
came to rely on the
information Gwen provided
and the discussions she led.
That trust was born from one
of Gwen's cardinal rules,
no predictions.
Guests on Washington
Week who trafficked
in theories or speculation
were not invited back.
She kept her focus and ours on
what was known, how we knew it,
and why it mattered.
When we think about Gwen
and Judy as individuals,
we find insight, persistence,
achievement, and personal
and professional integrity.
Both were recognized
for those qualities
when assigned to moderate
presidential and vice
presidential debates,
interview world leaders,
and report on the most
important stories of the day.
But what we saw when
they came together
as co-anchors of PBS News Hour
was capability and chemistry
at the highest levels.
And the connection that
Gwen and Judy shared
extended to the entire News
Hour family of correspondents
and commentators, so much so
that we, as audience members,
felt a part of it as well.
We are pleased to
be joined here today
by some of the many
journalists that Gwen and Judy
have inspired and championed
over the years as mentors
and colleagues, as well as
with their friends and family.
It is hard to imagine anyone
better-suited to converse
with Judy than Walter Isaacson.
His omnivorous intellect has
led to an impressive journalism
career, leadership of
the Aspen Institute,
and the award-winning
biographies of leading figures
from the 18th through
the 21st centuries,
including Benjamin
Franklin, Albert Einstein,
and Steve Jobs.
Who better to help us examine
the state of journalism
at present?
Who better to shed light on the
contributions of our honorees?
And who better, if
it's not too much
to ask, Walter, to give us
some hope for the future?
Please join me in welcoming
Walter Isaacson and Judy
Woodruff to the stage.
[APPLAUSE]
- Thank you.
- Thank you, Dean.
Thank you, Liz.
Congratulations, Judy.
This is a huge honor, and I
cannot think of anybody who
deserves this honor, or to
share with the memory of Gwen,
than you.
So congratulations.
- Thank you.
I am humble.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
- Our panel this
morning spent a lot
of time talking about truth--
in a place where
Veritas is revered,
how we've lost that as the
true north of all journalism
in our political discourse.
One of the things that you
and Gwen shared so much
was an intellectual honesty.
And there are very few people
we could look at and say,
if they are saying it,
they believe it to be true.
Tell us about the
quality in Gwen
and how that helped
shape your journalism.
- Well, first of all, I'm just
incredibly honored to be here.
This is just a moment.
I know Gwen is looking down
on all of us right now,
so sorry that she can't
be here, but thrilled
that she is represented
by her amazing mentees
and her close friends, who we're
going to hear from a little bit
later.
And Walter, you
knew Gwen very well.
So you know, as I do, she
really wanted to be here today.
So I think of her as
sitting right next to me.
- She's certainly smiling
with that amazing smile
down upon us.
- She is.
How to begin about Gwen
is, she represented--
you all know what an
incredible journalist she was.
The thing was, when we came
together at the News Hour,
she had been there since 1999.
I came back to the
News Hour in 2007.
And we knew each other.
We were friendly.
But we hadn't been colleagues.
And I was thinking about
this a lot last night.
We probably regarded each
other a little carefully
in the beginning.
We're both competitive.
We both had been doing.
We've had heads down
for years and years.
And so it took a few months--
maybe a year or so-- for
us to be really comfortable
with each other in the newsroom.
But once we got to
know each other--
once we knew that we both
believed in the same things--
and Walter, this comes
to your question--
and once I saw up
close all the things
that I had heard about
Gwen, knew about Gwen,
I recognized that I was in
the presence of somebody who
was emblematic of the kind of
journalism that I believe in,
that should be the
journalism that persists.
She was absolutely relentless
in pursuit of facts.
She was bold in the way
she approached people,
fearless in the way she talked
about the kind of stories
we were going to do.
I'll just tell you,
in a morning meeting,
we're discussing what to put
on the News Hour that night.
We might go around the table
and everybody would chime in,
this is a great idea,
that's a great idea.
And Gwen would be the
one to say, you know,
that's really a terrible
idea, and here's why.
And she would go
on and explain it.
And so it was that
quality of Gwen--
it was getting right to
the heart of the matter.
And it was always thinking of
everybody else in the room.
She was always the one who was
looking to the younger staff,
to the desk assistant who
had just come on our team
and was there and was
quiet and holding back.
Gwen would be the first one to
know that young man or young
woman's name, to pull them
out, and to recognize that her
role-- that our
role, eventually,
as we were named anchors
and managing editors--
was to model for them what's
important about journalism.
- Tell me about y'all being
named managing editors.
Jim Lehrer decides to step down.
Did this come as a
surprise that they
were going to pull the
two of you together?
- Well, when Jim
first stepped down,
we had a rotating
set of anchors there,
because we had an amazing
team of correspondents.
All of you who watched
the News Hour know this.
But Margaret Warner,
Jeffrey Brown, Ray Suarez
was with us at the time.
And of course, we have
some incredible journalists
who have joined us since then.
But in the beginning, there
was a rotation system.
And then in 2013, the
decision was made to name Gwen
and me co-anchors.
We had already worked
together the year
before, co-anchoring and
sitting at the conventions--
the Democratic and
Republican conventions.
In 2012, we had anchored
election night together.
We were working very closely
together at that time.
And Walter, what I'll tell
you was when we were named
and when it was clear that this
was really going to happen,
we had a long,
private talk together.
And we decided that what was the
most important thing of all was
that not only--
I already knew what an
incredible journalist
Gwen is, I know what
a friend she was
to me and to so many others.
But more than anything, we knew
that we had each other's back.
I knew if I messed up on
the air, said something,
she was going to be the
one to gently correct it.
She didn't make
mistakes, so I didn't
have to worry about doing that.
But quite seriously, we
had each other's backs.
- Well, wait, tell me more
about that conversation.
This was a real, physical,
a dinner or something?
And what did you all say?
- Well, it was actually a
number of dinners and lunches
and conversation that just
went on for days and days.
But this was after knew we
were taking over the show.
And what Gwen
always said to me--
and I want to say
this again, because I
think it came up in the
panel earlier this morning--
we view our role
at the News Hour
as the custodians of something
that's been handed to us.
What Robin MacNeil and
Jim Lehrer started in 1975
after the Watergate
hearings-- they
came together to create
MacNeil-Lehrer Report.
The kind of journalism
they believe in
is the kind of journalism
we believe in--
journalism that is about
informing and, when we can,
analyzing and clarifying and
bringing light and not heat.
And I know that's
become a cliche.
You hear it all the time.
But we really do mean it.
And we really do mean
that we're not here
to have a noisy argument.
It's got to remain civil.
But it has to also remain vital.
People have to feel
when they're watching,
when they're
engaging in whatever
we're doing, whether it's
online or even in social media,
that we're doing something
that they understand matters
to them.
So Gwen and I were committed
to that and that we were really
just the temporary
custodians of the News Hour.
We want the News Hour
to be passed on to--
I think Jonah Goldberg
said this earlier--
we want the
journalism we do to be
passed on to the next
generation and the next one.
And so whatever we
do right now, we
knew was going to set an example
for the young people around us.
- Well, that's what it is
to be part of an institution
is to realize it's larger
than just yourself.
And one of the things
you brought to it--
I know we're celebrating
Gwen-- but very much
you personally brought
to it, too, was
that deeply earnest honesty.
And I remember when we were
young and in our salad days
and you were covering Jimmy
Carter and then you and Al
and I doing Reagan,
there was just
no question of having a
private or secret agenda.
How do you bring that
into a world today?
- Well, again, this came out
in the panel this morning,
and I think everybody was there.
No politician wants
to bring bad news.
No politician wants to
share the worst things
that are going on in his or
her life or his or her career
or whatever battle he
or she is engaged in.
So you don't expect
you go to a politician
and they're going
to bare their soul.
You go into covering
politics, understanding
that they want to give you--
they're always going to want
to give you the best side.
Having said that, you
do expect them to level
with you at ground level--
that they're not
going to mislead you
about the fundamentals
of what they believe in.
And that is what I think
we want to preserve
in this country that--
- Has that changed?
- Well, I think
in some respects,
it has, because I think today--
I think because of this crazy,
complicated media environment
we're in-- and we
can talk about this--
I think it's easier
for politicians
to skirt around what is the
core that they're working on,
what is the core
of their belief.
And when they do that,
they don't necessarily
want to come clean.
They don't feel it's in their
interest to be straight.
But we, as reporters, have to
constantly ask those questions.
- But one of the things
about the media landscape
is that the
balkanization of it has
led to so much more
opinions but now,
as we heard this morning,
also different sets of facts.
How do we fight against that?
- Well, first of all, there's
a place for opinion journalism.
Again, I'm going to quote
Jonah Goldberg again.
There is a place for
opinion journalism
in our great democratic society.
We are all about
debate and argument.
That's what makes us the
great country that we are.
But I came along with
the old-fashioned kind
of journalism in which you
have to base the opinion
on an agreed set of facts.
And yes, you can debate
around the margins.
But to say, I'm going to ignore
an entire set of data that
has been clearly
backed up, and say,
we're not going to
look at that, we're
going to go in
another direction,
because it doesn't
suit our argument--
I don't think that
serves us as a democracy.
- And do we have the right--
I say "we," been
a while since I've
been a journalist-- the right
to now say, that's just a lie?
Because we used to not say that.
- You're right.
We didn't.
I'm pretty careful
about calling something
a lie, because to me, a lie gets
at the motivation behind what
somebody--
I think we can comfortably
say, if we know what
someone has said is false--
if we know demonstrably
that this happened--
that A happened and the
person said B happened,
we can point that out.
Absolutely, we can.
We should.
Calling someone a liar
or saying, that is a lie,
you're ascribing
a motive to them.
I don't think we
need to do that.
I think our viewers, the
people who follow us,
follow any news organization--
you're smart enough to know
if--
you know what happened if
you've seen it reported,
if you've read enough about it.
And if the politician or
whomever you're talking to
is telling it a
completely different way,
or the journalist, you
see the difference.
And so it's self-evident.
- Those of you who were
at the panel this morning
know by quoting Jonah
Goldberg a few times,
we're trying to
destroy his career
by having him favorably accepted
in Cambridge, Massachusetts.
And we're waiting for
Breitbart to come down on him.
But one of the
things he also said
was that we totally missed it--
that it wasn't just
about Donald Trump,
and it wasn't just
that we didn't quite
understand Donald Trump-- that
for the past 10 to 15 years,
we have missed what's happening
that's not on the coast.
- Oh, I think there is an
absolute truth to that, Walter.
I think for all the
good things that
have happened in the media,
we've got more smart,
young people coming in.
We've got reporters today
who've been to law school.
They've been to graduate school.
They're much more
steeped in science
or whatever the subject
matter that they're covering.
So we've got smarter
reporters than we've ever had.
We've got more sources
of information.
But I would also argue that we
have climbed into our little
comfortable places.
And much of it, as we
know, is right here
on the east coast,
separated only
by a few hours on the Acela.
Between Washington and New
York and Boston, we're here.
We're doing great work.
But what about the
rest of the country?
What about places like
Pennsylvania, like Michigan,
like my birth state of Oklahoma,
like Colorado, New Mexico where
yes, there's some
journalism, but there
isn't enough of the
kind of journalism
to really understand
what people's lives are.
- So what are you
doing at the News Hour
to try to remedy this?
- Well, we are
doing everything we
can to talk to people,
to send reporters out,
to get a sense of America,
whether the subject is
health care, education,
science, politics--
to talk to Americans
in all walks of life,
no matter where they live.
But you know what, Walter?
It gets at the business
model of journalism.
Everybody here knows
newspapers have closed down
by the hundreds and hundreds
over the last decade, 15 years.
We've lost tens of
thousands of reporters.
We don't have as many people
out asking questions, doing
the kind of deep,
dirty, hard work,
document reporting that we need
to understand this country.
And without that and
without people getting out
into these places, whether it's
Michigan, Oregon, you name it,
and talking, again, to
real people on the ground,
understanding their lives, we
can't reflect this country back
to--
my view of what
journalism is, is we
should be holding a mirror
up to the American people.
We should be saying, here's
where we're doing well,
and here's where we
need work, and here's
what you need to know to be a
good citizen, to make decisions
about not just how
you're going to vote,
but how to think about the
people who are making decisions
for you in Washington.
And unless we are out there
talking to those people,
getting their view,
hearing from them,
and, frankly,
respecting that view,
even when it differs
from ours, and giving it
equal time or more time,
then I don't think--
we're not doing our job holding
up a mirror to this country.
I think we've done a lot
of things really well.
But I also think we've
got a lot of work
to do when it comes
to that mirror.
And I mean that in every regard.
We've done a much
better job, I think,
of including women in
the work that we do,
of including minorities,
although, goodness knows,
we've got so much
more work to do there.
But we also need to get
out and cover people
who live in rural areas and
cover the industries that we
don't see on the east coast.
- Also, the destruction of the
business model for journalism--
EJ said it's the best
and worst of times.
It's, in some ways, the best of
times for a lot of journalism
but the worst of times
for a business model.
That's decimated
international reporting.
How do you try to keep
that in the forefront?
- Well, what we've done,
I can just tell you,
at the News Hour-- and I know
other news organizations are
committed to this.
They've deployed correspondents.
Between the Associated Press,
The New York Times, Wall Street
Journal, Washington Post, and
so many other organizations
that have just absolutely
remained committed
to covering the world, despite
the resource challenges that we
all face, what we've had
to do is work more and more
in partnership.
We have partnership with
the Pulitzer Center,
for example-- the Pulitzer
Center for Crisis Reporting--
with other, frankly,
new organizations
that have cropped up that are
able to get correspondents,
reporters into countries that
we otherwise wouldn't be in.
We had a reporter, for
example, in South Sudan
doing several pieces for
us just a few days ago.
We've had reporters in
Iraq and other places.
We don't have the wherewithal
on the News Hour budget
to go cover these places
and cover them all the time.
So we have to enter into
these partnership agreements.
And we're trying to do that
all the time-- to get people
into whether it's
China, Korea, Taiwan.
There are so many
parts of the planet
that I think go uncovered,
or it's insufficiently
covered right now.
- What do you say to those
who say that the News
Hour and the mainstream press,
in general, is just too elite,
too aimed at a certain group--
aging, elite group.
I'm speaking to a tent
full of the aging elites.
So we're not necessarily
against that.
- You're not going to let him
get away with it, are you?
- But isn't there an elitism to
some of what you've just said--
that people don't want this, but
we're going to still try to do
it?
- Well, in terms of
age, this is anecdotal.
But last night, as I'm waiting
at the Washington National
Airport to fly to Boston,
a couple of 20-somethings
came up to me with their
boyfriends and said,
we never miss the News
Hour, we watch it together.
They--
[APPLAUSE]
- Good.
- We did selfies.
And I expected them to say
they listened to us on podcast
or on their wristwatch.
They said, no, we sit in front
of a television and watch.
But to get to your question,
sure, our audience skews older.
Those are the folks who grew
up with Walter Cronkite,
Huntley-Brinkley,
John Chancellor, who
was a mentor of mine when
I was at NBC, and others.
And that's perfectly fine.
But we also have to be
madly figuring out--
and we are-- how to reach
the younger generation.
And that means being
available wherever they are.
And so without getting into
all the nitty gritty of it,
if you've checked out our
web page PBS.org/NewsHour,
you will see there are many,
many more stories there than we
possibly would have room
to put on the program.
But again, Walter, to your
point about being elite--
and I think it
reflects back to what
I said a moment ago--
this is something
we have to worry about.
I looked around our
newsroom the other day.
We've all gone to good colleges.
We've gotten a great education.
We live in Washington
or New York
or one of these great,
amazing centers of higher
education on the east coast.
Are we really in touch
with most Americans?
And I don't want
to repeat myself.
But we've got to work at that.
We've got to bring journalists
into the newsroom who
come from outside of
Washington and New York.
As I said, I was born
in Tulsa, Oklahoma.
I grew up as an army brat
living all over the world.
I lived in Missouri
and New Jersey and back
in Oklahoma and Georgia--
Augusta, Georgia--
for a number of years.
So I bring a little of that.
But it was a long time ago.
We need young people coming in
from all parts of this country
and internationally
who can reflect
the different backgrounds
that they bring.
In fact, it's something
Gwen and I used
to talk about all the time.
We have to have a diversity of
backgrounds in this newsroom,
or we're not doing our job.
We're not reflecting
this country.
We have to do that.
And we have to guard
against that elite mindset
that only those folks who
went to good colleges--
they have a reservoir,
and they know everything.
And yes, they're smart.
And gosh knows, they bring
great ideas to what we do.
And we need to broaden it out.
- One of the things you
and Gwen broadened out
was the talking
heads on your show.
Suddenly, they
looked different, IE,
they weren't all just
white, male elite.
Was that a conscious effort?
How did you do that?
- It was a conscious effort.
It is a conscious effort.
It started under Jim Lehrer
and even before that.
As you may remember, the
first sidekick, if you will,
for Jim Lehrer and Robert
MacNeil was Charlayne
Hunter-Gault who
was a remarkable--
[APPLAUSE]
- Still is.
- Give her a hand.
Still is.
Remarkable pioneer of the
Civil Rights Movement,
integrated the
University of Georgia--
she's still involved
in the program.
She still does special
reporting for us.
And of course, Charlayne
was with the program
for I think 15 years
and then with NPR.
So Jim and Robin, from
the very beginning,
have had a commitment to
women, have had a commitment
to diversity.
I joined the program
first in 1983.
They wanted a Washington
correspondent.
I left NBC to come
to the program,
because Jim and Robin
told me specifically,
we want a woman to have an
important role in the program.
And when I was off
wandering in the wilderness,
as Jim used to say,
of cable television--
- Wait, wait, wait.
We worked together.
- --where at one point,
Walter Isaacson was my boss
as president of CNN.
He knows where all
the bodies are buried.
But at that point when
I was away from the News
Hour was, of course,
when Gwen came in.
And it was because Jim
wanted somebody, of course,
with the amazing
journalist that Gwen is.
But it was the commitment to
making that newsroom look more
like the country.
- You've talked about a
couple of mentors already--
John Chancellor
and now Jim Lehrer.
Tell me about the
role of mentors
when you were a woman
coming up in the business.
- Well, I would love to tell you
that there were very many women
mentors.
The truth is, there
weren't any, because--
I think you heard the story
from Dean Cohen a minute ago--
when I applied for a job as a--
actually, I was applying
for a job as a secretary,
because they told me there
were no jobs for reporters.
The answer was, I guess we'll
hire you, but, as you said,
we already have a woman
reporter, how could you
possibly be interested?
After I went to work
as a reporter, one
of the men in the newsroom
said, we've already
got one blonde reporter,
why do we need anybody
else here who wears skirts?
It was this kind of open
attitude, if you will.
But you know what?
It never deterred me.
I have to give credit to my
amazing mother who passed away
four years ago.
She not only didn't
go to college,
she couldn't finish high school.
She barely was able
to finish 10th grade.
Her father passed away.
She stayed home to take
care of her siblings.
And she always said to me,
get your education, diapers
and dishes can wait, get your
education, get your education.
And so I--
[APPLAUSE]
I carry that with
me every single day.
And when you ask, who
are my role models,
my mother was a role model,
even though she did not--
- From Oklahoma.
- She was born in Missouri,
grew up in Tulsa, Oklahoma.
She is my principal role model.
And beyond that, in this
career, there were women.
There was a woman
named Cassie Mackin
who covered politics for NBC--
- What a tragic tale.
- --who went out of her way--
who died tragically at such
a young age.
She went out of her
way to welcome me
when I joined NBC after I'd
been in local news in Atlanta.
And there have been
others along the way who
have been incredible.
- Well, Pauline Frederick,
Nancy Dickerson [INAUDIBLE].
- Nancy Dickerson,
Pauline Fred--
you've done your homework.
- No, no.
I'm just old.
I remember them all.
- And then of course,
along the way,
to be able to work
with the greats--
you can go down the list,
the women of my generation--
Lesley Stahl, Connie Chung,
Diane Sawyer-- the women
who came in about
the same time I have.
And today, look around--
not just in television,
but in print.
Look at the people
who are breaking news
right now in The New York
Times and The Washington Post--
Karen Tumulty at The Washington
Post, Ashley Parker--
the names come.
- Don't forget Maggie Haberman.
- I'm saying at The New York
Times, Maggie Haberman these
are reporters who are young and
doing remarkable work at all
these news organizations.
They're making a difference.
I have to say,
Walter, though, we
are not doing a good
enough job with women
in management of news.
Not a single head--
[APPLAUSE]
We are blessed at the News Hour.
Our executive producer
is a woman, Sara Just,
who succeeded another
woman executive
producer, Linda Winslow--
two phenomenal journalists.
The person who runs the station
that sponsors the News Hour,
Sharon Rockefeller--
she's the president
of WETA, our sponsoring station.
So we have amazing
women role model.
- And PBS.
- And PBS--
Paula Kerger is
the president, PBS.
So we're doing well.
We don't take
anything for granted.
But I will tell you, as I
look around the landscape,
there's not a woman running a
commercial broadcast network
news division, unless
something changed
in the last few minutes.
Look at the newspapers
in this country.
We don't have enough
women editors.
We need more Ann
Marie Lipinskis.
We need more Jill Abramsons.
We need more Amanda
Bennetts-- the women
who have run great newspapers,
been newspaper editors.
So we've come a long way.
But we have to keep pushing.
Why do you think, Walter?
I'm going to turn
the tables on you.
Why don't we have more women
bosses at these great news
organizations?
- It's endemic in our society.
I worry about it even
more in tech companies,
in Silicon Valley,
and innovation.
And I think it's still a
basic level of discrimination.
I think people-- one cut below
taking them as seriously as you
would a man saying--
you have seen it, and
I have seen it now
that I've tried to
be attuned to it.
Go around the table.
People have different ideas.
And yet, all the
sudden, a good idea
gets attributed to a man
who didn't actually say it.
- And yet, you have you have
multiple women presidents
of great universities--
Drew Faust, Nan
Keohane who's sitting
right here, who was president of
Duke University, my alma mater.
So we know there's a lot
of female talent out there.
But it's a complicated--
- So let me go back to Gwen.
Do you think that she felt more
of an obstacle being a woman
or being black?
- We had this conversation
on several occasions.
I know that she felt being a
person of color was harder.
But it was the dual package that
made it really hard for her.
Gwen didn't go around with
a chip on her shoulder.
She didn't go
around complaining.
That was not who she was.
But she was informed and
shaped by her own experiences.
And that's what made her the
remarkable, path-breaking,
relentless, never-say-die
journalist that she was,
because she had been through
what she went through
at the Boston Herald-- because
she experienced so much of that
on the campaign trail following
presidential candidates--
senatorial, gubernatorial
candidates--
interviewing people,
having people mistake her
for something else--
the maid in the
hotel, rather than
the person who was there
to interview the candidate.
She rose above all that.
And we would joke about it.
She was a PK, she called it--
Preacher's Kid.
I was an army brat, so we would
talk about the experience.
But there's no question that
her experience growing up
in the life that she had, the
obstacles she had overcome
helped to make her the pioneer,
the extraordinary journalist
that she was.
It shaped her.
And it made her more
powerful as a presence.
And we have to give her more
credit as a result of that.
She deserves--
[APPLAUSE]
I speak of her in the present
tense, because, like I said,
she's sitting right here.
She deserves much
more credit because
of what she and other
journalists of color
go through every day-- people
of color in this country go
through every day, still.
Here we are, how many
hundred and so many years
past the Civil War, and
we're still fighting.
And decades past the
Civil Rights Movement,
we still are fighting
these battles.
We are still on the
front lines, if you will.
And all of us have
to come together
to talk about it openly
and to confront it
and to get ahead of it,
because if we don't, we
are hurting the next generation
and the generation after them.
[APPLAUSE]
- I never heard her
be bitter or complain.
She was always-- almost
made light and up about it.
But you were in a
special bond with her.
What did you all talk
about when it got bad?
- Well, I haven't
even shared with you
the really important
link that we had.
I told this story at Gwen's
service after she died.
And that is that we
realized that if it
had been two guys sitting
next to each other,
you wouldn't have to worry about
two guys, two suits, two ties.
But with women, we couldn't
show up both wearing
red, both wearing yellow.
So we would email
each other each night,
wearing green, wearing pink.
But what we laughed about was
after a few months of doing
this, we just kind of
intuited what the other one
was going to wear.
We didn't even have to
do the emails anymore.
We just knew.
It.
There was one day when we
both showed up in blue.
And it was OK.
But when the going got tough,
we confided in each other.
I'd go into her office.
She would come into mine.
They were right
next to each other.
And we would say, oh, my
gosh, what are we going to do,
or we're going to get
through this together.
You can't work that--
- You have an example?
- No, I'm not going
to share this.
- Just with them.
- Office politics.
No, seriously.
No, what I'll say
is that what really
matters in a team, whether
you're a television anchor team
or whether you're
together running--
I'm sure this is the
case-- running a business
or running a university is that
the people at the top, the team
have to be able to
trust each other.
And we knew we had to trust each
other, as I said a minute ago,
have each other's backs,
or we couldn't convey.
We couldn't do our work and
project it for the audience.
When you're sitting there on
election night or at a debate
or at a convention--
for example,
as we did just last summer,
the Republican and Democratic
National conventions--
and it's spontaneous--
you don't know what's
going to happen--
you have to be able to trust, to
know that if you say something
stupid, that the
other person is going
to carefully, or sometimes
not so carefully, correct you.
- Bring you back.
- But we had that kind
of a relationship.
And I give her
almost all the credit
for that, because she was the
generous human being that she
was.
- Let me interrupt there,
because I know how generous
you've been to so many people.
So I know you share that
generosity, and it's important.
Let me end--
[APPLAUSE]
And I do think that you all
are the two most intellectually
honest people I know.
But you both, with
the spirit you had,
were the two most generous
people I know in the business.
The traditional last question--
- I'm going to start
to believe all this is,
so he's got to stop.
- It has the added
virtue of being true.
The traditional last
question for this awardee
is, what advice would you give
to a young person coming up
in your field?
We'll end with this.
- Jump in.
We need more good,
smart journalists today
than we have ever needed.
And this happens all the time.
They come up to
me in our newsroom
and as I move around
Washington and other places.
They come up and
they say, should I
really go into journalism,
what's happening to journalism?
And I say, look, I
can't tell you where
we're going to be in 10 years.
I can't even tell you where
we're going to be next year.
But what I can tell you is that
the American people are always
going to need reporters who
are prepared to put themselves
on the line, to go out there
with an insatiable curiosity,
find stories, find answers
to tough questions,
hold our public
leaders accountable.
We need the next generation
and the generation
after that to do that.
Jump in.
The water's great.
We need you.
We've never needed
you more than now.
So if you have the curiosity--
if you don't care what
kind of hours you keep--
if you can live on a little
bit of sleep and you love--
journalism is the most, to me--
I can't imagine doing anything
other than journalism.
What more interesting
field can there be?
You are constantly in contact
with interesting people.
So what I say to young
journalists is, jump in,
don't hesitate, get your
good liberal arts education,
and then think about
what part of journalism
you want to work in.
But there's always going to
be a need in our democracy
for great reporting.
- President Faust,
in her baccalaureate,
talked about the moral
imperative of noticing.
And you have been
an exemplar of that.
Thank you, Judy.
- Thank you.
I'm going to get this.
- Thank you so much.
- Bravo.
- OK.
Thank you.
OK.
- Thank you so much,
Walter and Judy,
for this illuminating
conversation.
Anyone who watched
Judy and Gwen could not
help but notice
the true friendship
that they seemed to share.
And I think we got a very good
look at that this afternoon.
A gift for friendship was
one of Gwen's many talents.
So I would like to invite
another of Gwen's closest
friends to the podium.
Please welcome
journalist and author
Michele Norris who will
accept Gwen's Radcliffe Medal
and share a few words.
[APPLAUSE]
Now I will read the citation
for Gwen's Radcliffe Medal.
"She raised tough
questions, told hard truths,
and held fiercely to fact.
She illuminated the news
to inform the public,
strengthen civil society, and
inspire future journalists."
Thank you, Michele Norris,
for accepting Gwen Ifill's
Radcliffe Medal, given with
our greatest admiration
for her excellence
in journalism.
[APPLAUSE]
- It is my great honor to accept
this award for my dear friend.
She so badly wanted
to be here today.
She was very humble, as you've
heard, in taking her laurels.
But she also enjoyed it.
She had a special
place in her home
where she posted all of her
awards and her mini hoods.
And she knew, in
part, that when she
was able to accept
an award like this,
she was able to shine her
light in a special way
so those who came
behind her could see it.
You've heard over and over
and over again, mentoring
was important to Gwen.
Telling hard truths
was important.
But holding those
truths up was important,
but also holding her life up
as an example was important.
She would have loved
that this happened here
in Boston, because
her road to journalism
began here in Boston.
And Dean, you talked
about the story--
what happened in the newsroom,
the horrible thing that
was written at her desk.
You saw the beginnings of who
she became as a journalist
and as a person in how
she responded to that.
She thought that, that
can't possibly be for me.
And she just kept going.
She would have
loved that this was
in an institution of learning,
because she felt so strongly
that she wanted to spend time.
And even when she was
struggling with her illness,
she still made time
to be with mentors
and to be with young
people, because she
wanted them to follow her
into the role of journalism.
As a woman of color--
I'm not going to share
her age, because she
would fuss at me
for doing something
like that at a podium--
but as a woman of
her generation,
it meant that she
was often the first.
She rolled the mantle of
being the first person--
the first person to host
a presidential debate
as a woman of color,
the first person to host
a major political program.
And that helps you understand
who she was as a journalist.
But I want to talk a
little bit, if I can,
in just a few moments
about the first
that she represented that
also helped us understand
who she was as a human being.
Yes, she was the first person
to ask a tough question.
She was the first person
to see holes in a story.
She was the first
person to submit copy.
She was a wicked fast writer.
She was the first person
often to spot trends
or to push boundaries
and enforce standards.
But she was also
the first person,
as Judy mentioned, to
help a young reporter.
She was the first person to make
herself available to someone
new in the newsroom.
She was the first, and
sometimes the only,
person to take the time to greet
the security guards every day.
She knew their names.
She knew their birthdays.
She knew when their kids
were graduating from college.
She was the first to sing "Happy
Birthday" to the woman who
answered the phones
at The Washington Post
when we first worked together.
I met Gwen at The
Washington Post.
And it was almost 30 years ago.
And for the past 30 years,
we've lived about five blocks
from each other.
She was my best friend.
She was the maid of
honor in my wedding.
She is godmother to my children.
And I got to know her well.
And so I also
understood that she
knew that if you exercised
power in small ways,
you could more easily claim
the mantle in other ways.
And so she was the
first to call someone
during tough times, the first to
arrive to help lay out the hors
d'oeuvres for a nervous host,
because she could spot that.
She was the first to understand
and enforce the first rule
of friendship-- no competition.
We remained friends,
even though we often
competed with each
other in the newsroom.
Our career paths followed
a similar trajectory.
We met at The Washington Post.
She went to NBC.
I went to ABC.
She went to PBS.
I went to NPR.
And Judy, you
should know that we
were informed by watching you
and your years-long and lovely
and very strong friendship
with Andrea Mitchell.
We knew that we would be
stronger if we held together.
And we decided not to
compete against each other.
She was the first, as
one of our dear friends
told us, to know what
you needed before you
knew what you needed,
the first to say
"yes" to be by your side.
Ertharin Cousin is
in the audience.
And she, for a number of years,
was Director of the World Food
Program in Italy.
And when Gwen figured
that she was lonely,
she was the first
to say, you know
what, I think you need
someone by your side,
even if it meant
jumping the pond
and going to visit her in Italy.
She was the first, as
[INAUDIBLE] told me today,
to tell us that
it's going to be OK,
even when she wasn't even
sure of it of herself.
But she could help
us understand that.
She was OK with being the first.
But she always wanted to make
sure that she was not the last.
So she knew that she
couldn't just bust down doors
but that she had
to hold them open.
You see, it's easier
to bust down a door
than to actually hold it open.
You can muscle your
way through a door.
But if you hold
the door open, it
means that you have to stay
at that door sometimes when
other people-- you can hear
them in the distance having fun,
moving on, doing other things.
To hold the door open, you
have to lift while you climb.
You have to always be
thinking of the people who
are coming behind you.
And so maybe we can think
about that, particularly
in a room full of so
many accomplished women.
What are we doing not
just to open the door--
[APPLAUSE]
--but to hold the door open?
Gwen used to talk about
colored girl moments.
We were brown girls raised in
a country that didn't imagine
these kinds of jobs for us.
And on big days, she would
call and she would say,
I had a colored
girl moment today,
I interviewed Elton John,
I interviewed Colin Powell.
This would have been
a colored girl moment.
She would have
loved this moment.
I'm wearing a very
bright jacket today.
My husband said
that if I wore this,
I would look like a
walking highlighter.
[LAUGHTER]
But I share this because
it reflects a colored girl
moment for Gwen.
You will remember
her from hosting
a series of vice
presidential debates
and, not long ago with
Judy, a presidential debate
in Milwaukee with Hillary
Clinton and Bernie Sanders.
When she first did the first
vice presidential debate
with Dick Cheney
and John Edwards,
she was told by the vice
presidential committee
that maybe she should wear a
demure jacket, because that's
what the guys always do.
They wore something dark.
And it would make her look
more authoritative, they said.
I went shopping
with Gwen when she
decided what she was going to
wear for that first debate.
And if you remember
her picture--
and again, when she was
portrayed by Queen Latifah,
she also wore the
same color jacket--
and it was a very bright
and resplendent blue.
She was not going to
wear something dark.
And you know why she decided--
at least one reason why
she decided-- to wear
that bright colored jacket?
She said, I want to make sure
the ancestors can see me.
[LAUGHTER, APPLAUSE]
And so when she hosted
her second debate,
she wore turquoise, doing
that with a broken ankle,
as we remember.
And when she did the
debate in Milwaukee,
she was resplendent in purple.
She wanted the
ancestors to see her,
but she also wanted
people who were coming
behind her to see her as well.
She's forever holding
open doors, even now,
through her legacy, which
we uphold through our work
and which Radcliffe
upholds with this award.
I loved being her friend.
I am only now getting used to
saying that in the past tense.
It will never feel right.
I cherished being her colleague.
And I am so very honored
to accept this award
on her behalf.
From the entire Ifill family,
thank you very, very much.
[APPLAUSE]
- And now Judy,
finally, the time
has come to award
your Radcliffe Medal.
And I will now read the
citation we've written for you.
"She exemplifies intelligence,
integrity, and determination.
She pursues truth with
courage and conviction.
She inspires us all to
safeguard freedom of the press
as an essential foundation
of our democracy."
Judy Woodruff, I
bestow upon you,
and if you would come
forward, this Radcliffe
Medal, with the deepest
admiration for a lifetime
of excellence in journalism.
[APPLAUSE]
- Thank you.
This is so special.
Thank you, Liz.
- And then this is your--
- Thank you.
Thank you.
Wow.
- And I'll give
you the little box.
So you can take that.
- Oh, good.
Thank you.
I'm very touched.
- Well, it's been quite a day.
Thank you, of course, to Judy
and to Michele and to Walter
and to our wonderful panelists
this morning for giving us
an incredible experience.
And I just want to
thank all of you
here in the audience for helping
to make today's Radcliffe
Day so special.
So thank you for joining
us for Radcliffe Day 2017.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]